Kim Kardashian just spoke at Harvard
Business School
this has caused a major stir
someone suggested they said Kim
Kardashian speaking at Harvard Business
School well there goes all of Harvard's
Prestige and I thought well Harvard's
prestige
the the most impressive
Harvard students are the ones who drop
out
Harvard's Prestige Bill Gates
Mark Zuckerberg the list goes on and
they're the ones that drop out Harvard's
prestige
Harvard's Prestige one of the most
famous Harvard students
I think a graduate to Harvard I believe
that he actually graduated one of one of
the most impressive Harvard students in
recent years is the Unabomber
Harvard's Prestige Harvard's lucky to
have Kim Kardashian however it actually
is lucky to have Kim Kardashian
especially at the business school
because she was there to talk about her
shapewear company skims
put a pause right there what is a
shapewear company I don't know what I
assume it's a clothing kind of company
shapewear that's very strange
uh they they
listened at this school to a two-hour
lecture
as part of a direct to Consumer seminar
uh Kim Kardashian is a co-founder of
this company skims
it's a multi-billion dollar company uh
it launched a private Equity Firm called
Sky Partners uh uh skims recently
doubled its valuation from 1.6 billion
to 3.2 billion over a period of just
nine months as investors rushed to
acquire equity in that company and Kim
goes on launches this private Equity
company I don't know she's pretty
impressive to me
at least by the standard of Business
School
I don't know that Kim Kardashian has
read a lot of old poetry or Greek
philosophy or anything like that
but the woman knows a thing or two about
business
and there's a big difference between a
liberal arts education which is what a
lot of people seek for an undergraduate
education and a business school
education or a law school education or a
medical school education those are those
are trades that's vocational training to
learn a job
so I agree it would probably be
inappropriate for Kim Kardashian who is
famous for
she's famous for showing off her body on
camera and then having a reality TV show
launched from that
it would be probably inappropriate for
her to go lecture on
nostrevsky or something on Aristotle at
Harvard undergraduate but in terms of
business school yeah she's she's one of
the most successful businessmen in the
country
and and business school is largely a
farce including Harvard Business School
including all the all the really
prominent Business Schools the purpose
of business school is not to really
educate yourself all that much it's
mostly for networking it can be a
credential if you want to move up the
management hierarchy but if you want to
be an entrepreneur and launch your own
business it's really the whole point of
it is just networking you don't
you don't need to actually do that much
in terms of scholarly rigor to be in
business school and I just I find it I
hate to take Kim Kardashian's side in
almost any matter but
it it's just so
absurdly
elitist it's so baselessly elitist
for anyone to suggest oh Kim Kardashian
she has no right to to lecture at this
school what are you Kim Kardashian is
more successful than any of the people
that she is lecturing will ever be in
terms of business Acumen and business
success I would be willing to bet a
significant amount of money that not one
person in that lecture hall will ever
make more money or be more successful in
business than Kim Kardashian business
school like so much of our higher
education structure these days is pretty
much a joke actually here's the proof
there's an amazing story just came out
yesterday from Wharton School of
Business Wharton is arguably the best
business school in the country Harvard
is also up there but but Wharton out of
UPenn is one of the very top schools in
the country
and chat GPT
which is an AI program I just did very
well on some Wharton business school
exams
this is a mass-market artificial
intelligence chat bot it was launched by
open AI I've played around on it I'm
sure a lot of other people have played
around on this on the software as well
well a research paper from Wharton uh
from this professor Christian turvish
said that chat gbt earned a grade
between a b and a B minus on a final
exam that is usually presented to MBA
students
what does this mean
this I mean it's kind of funny and maybe
it shows you the business school isn't
all that hard and maybe it shows you
that artificial intelligence is really
impressive
the most important thing this tells you
is that
the current line about artificial
intelligence is backwards the current
line about artificial intelligence is
that AI is going to replace all those
those useless low-skilled workers this
is what you hear from from people like
Yuval Harare or some of the world
economic foreign types that say oh you
know we're going to have all these
useless people in the future because of
Automation and so we'll just apply them
with drugs and video games and
usually what they mean by useless people
the poor people the uneducated people
the service worker type people they're
going to be replaced by automation
chat GPT Wharton business school is
showing it's the opposite
the useless people
are the white-collar workers in most
cases
not not not all of them but a lot of
them chat CPT shows quote a remarkable
ability to automate some of the skills
of Highly compensated knowledge workers
in general and specifically the
knowledge workers in the jobs held by
MBA graduates it does an amazing job at
basic operations management and process
analysis questions including those that
are based on case studies not only are
the answers correct but the explanations
are excellent
right
it's it is true that at McDonald's now
sometimes there will be fewer workers
because you can place your orders on
machines
but you still have workers there
okay and McDonald's is one of the the
most automated of any restaurant chain
when you go out to a restaurant where
you actually want a dining experience
that is always going to have people
involved in it
because people augment that experience
you want the waiter to come over in the
nice coat with the tie and say Mr so and
so can I get you a drink oh I recommend
having the pasta with the steak or you
want that Human Experience that's that's
part of what makes going out to dinner
special
you don't want Thelma to come over thumb
of the robot and say beep boop Martini
or Manhattan beep beep boop you know
just starts frying and that's that
wouldn't be fun and special
use you want that human contact you were
going to want you even as robots become
more common in our homes you're still
going to want people with their judgment
with that human touch with their
artistic ability to go in and operate
certain aspects of the service economy
I'm not sure that you need any human
beings to operate most of business and
management and white collar jobs
the people who should be really afraid
here
are all those white collar laptop
workers all the ones who tell the poor
Rust Belt Americans who whose
politicians betrayed them and who
shipped their jobs overseas the the ones
who say well just learn to code keep up
yeah the ones we're going to need to
learn to code are going to be largely
white-collar workers and they're never
going to learn to code better than chat
GPT so I don't know maybe it's time to
learn to plumb
time to learn to install electrical
wires
and to learn time to learn a useful
trade I would suggest the show continues
now you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles Canada wlas at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
we'll see you in the member block
[Music]